let me warn you our main story tonight
is going to end with you getting
extremely angry at a donkey that might
not make sense right now but it is going
to so let's let's begin translation
we've all seen the comic ways in which
it can go wrong the Chinese signs that
say things like do drunken driving or
vegetables to be fair yes that's a silly
sign but at the same time maybe you've
seen the YouTube videos where people put
songs like let it go into Google
Translate then translate them back into
English and sing the results
[Music]
[Applause]
I've got to say that would be an amazing
tone for the frozen sequel a bitter
woman warbling about two feet in a
radioactive ice castle I am bad
translation can be a lot of fun when the
stakes are low but if you're in a war
zone accurate translation can be the
difference between life and death
and over the last decade good local
interpreters in Afghanistan and Iraq
have saved countless American lives let
me show you an Afghani man at named
Sirach translating a warning about some
IEDs to infidel means people know
commencement he says that there's I did
someone told me that there is IDs in
this way I'm very attached to the burial
energy the ability to see the real
predetermined idea particularly
okay thank you you see that is a good
message to get exactly right you don't
want someone saying oh to be honest Maya
patch toes a little shaky but there's
either an AED or an Ikea behind those
rocks somewhere also I think he said
something about vegetables something ask
any veteran and they will tell you that
translators risked their own lives
working for us and because they did that
they are permanent targets for
insurgents here's what the translator
you just saw Sirach has been up to
lately
my relatives told me that hey Josh be
careful the bad people looking for you
and please run away I'm afraid of that
Bay which donato leave Afghanistan the
United States forces to leave
Afghanistan it means we are done
they're going to catch me they're going
to probably cut my head off probably you
know you're probably thinking right now
well we need to move heaven and earth to
get that man and his family and bring
them to safety and the fact that we are
not is what this story is about because
Sirach like a shocking number of
interpreters has applied for a visa but
is stuck in bureaucratic limbo and the
crazy thing is there was absolutely no
good reason for that Congress passed
bills in 2008 and 2009 providing
thousands of special immigrant visas for
local nationals who worked with the US
military
but despite huge demand very few were
issued for instance through the
Afghanistan bill we could have given out
up to 1,500 visas a year guess how many
we gave out in 2011 it was three the
number of visas for Afghan EES who
risked their lives for us should not be
so low that relatively stupid toddlers
can count up to it relatively
intelligent horses one - shouldn't it be
more than this three now now to be fair
things have improved slightly recently
thanks in part to pressure from groups
like the list project and I wrap but it
is still not moving nearly fast enough
help us understand just how difficult it
is for Afghans who worked with US forces
to get these special visas it's next to
impossible I would say it to Kindle it
literally winning the lottery yep it
should not be like a lottery where the
odds are terrible these people risk
their lives for us it should be more
like a little league award ceremony
where everyone's a winner because
they're all an important part of the
team
there are currently thousands of
interpreters with visa applications
pending and if you're wondering whose
focuses the State Department has a
surprising answer Jarett Blanc is a
deputy Special Representative for
Afghanistan and Pakistan at the State
Department he blamed some of the delays
on the applicants themselves a lot of
those people are actually maybe not
quite half of them are control their own
timing essentially so they've started
the application or perhaps they've
gotten through the first step but they
need to finish their own paperwork
before we can take the next step with
them oh that is some first-class
victim-blaming you are on the edge of
saying well look maybe the Taliban
wouldn't be following them around if
these translators weren't dressed so
have you thought about that but
but since he brings up the paperwork
let's just take a look at it because
applying for a special immigrant visa is
a fourteen step process which is a lot
bear in mind that even getting off
heroin only takes 12 are you ready for
this let's do it because first
you've got your DS 157 form this
contains all your basic information it
also needs to come with a verification
of employment letter from an HR director
as well as a letter of recommendation
from a direct supervisor now if you
can't find your former supervisor which
is entirely possible don't worry you
just need a D s 158 supervisor locator
form although that will only work if
your supervisor was directly employed by
the military if they were a contractor
which they probably were you're out
of luck you will also need to submit a
proof of nationality form and a copy of
your employee badge because no one has
ever lost one of those and once you've
filled all of this in you simply submit
it for approval and then wait for
anything between a few months and a few
years and if you're approved then
congratulations because you are at the
petition stage for this you are going to
need your a 364 which is basically the D
s 157 form all over again or and
remember to bring that to your interview
at the US Embassy although in
Afghanistan funny story they're not
scheduling those at the moment partly
because the system so backed up and
partly because this whole program is set
to expire at the end of the year for no
reason whatsoever at this stage
as a translator may feel a little like
this but don't don't because there is
light at the end of the tunnel well well
not light so much as the ds2 64 and this
little beauty contains such questions as
are you coming to the u.s. to practice
polygamy to which I'm guessing your
answer is to be honest my main plan was
to not get killed by the Taliban
I hadn't really worked out a plan of
attack for my sex life yet because after
all this paperwork plus of course a visa
interview and medical examination
security clearance and paying out of
pocket for passports vaccinations and
your own plane tickets you get to come
to America or as one translator
discovered not I'm a proof from the SIV
that the passport everything is done
after that they just give me this this
card you will be not really interviewed
you will be received in a several months
you'll release it and this is nine
months ago so what what's the problem
they denied my visa
what love but now the ghost of Franz
Kafka is thinking don't you dare call
this Kafka risk I don't want my name
anywhere near this
waking up as a cockroach is normal this
whole process makes no sense and I
understand the need for security
screenings but America has done this
quicker before after the Vietnam War the
u.s. resettled a hundred and forty
thousand refugees in just four months we
did it perfectly at the end of the
Vietnam War and there is a sentence you
don't often get to say out loud but what
we did was we took everyone to Guam and
process them there in safety so why are
we just doing that again
what else are we gonna do with Guam its
quad its it's 200 square miles of palm
trees and storage space its Guam and
while the US government may have doubts
about some of these translators the
troops who've served alongside them
certainly don't
because you remember Sirach well the
Marines he served we've created a
crowdfunding page to finance his medical
exams well you can recommend such as
thanks brother for helping us survive
and return to our families alive and
thanks for saving our ass so many times
time to get you stateside and it is both
inspiring and horrifying that the life
of a man who saved Americans is in the
hands of the same process through which
we finance Zach Braff's shitty movies
let me show you just one more place
Muhammad an Afghani translator who
started his application in September
2010 and finally made it to America
three years and four months later so at
least he's here there is that but this
was the atmosphere in which he had to do
that waiting the people who they're
trying to hurt me first they killed me
dead and at the next day of their tried
to kill my brothers the they took my
letter brother which I love him more
than everyone they once they talked him
and they told me to pay almost $35,000
that's right
they kidnapped his three-year-old
brother and he spent his entire life
savings to get him back and at that
point it was already two and a half
years into his application process and
having gone through all that when
Mohammed finally got his visa a clerical
error resulted in his name being
officially changed to F nu Mohammed
which is an acronym for first name
unknown meaning that on official
documents to all intents and purposes
his name is now for knew and for knew is
for not a for knocking for name I know
we can do this quicker not just because
of Guam because there is at least one
other documented case of an evacuation
Iraq who did get processed faster smoked
the Iraqi donkey is in the u.s. smoke
the donkey wandered onto a military base
in 2008 and was Brooke friend befriended
by some US Marines they have brought the
donkey to the United States smoke is now
an American it was a long process I want
to say that we started this probably
back in September of 2010 remember who
else started his application in
September of 2010 Mohammed it took smoke
the donkey eight months to get to
America
it took Mohammed nearly three and a half
years see I told you this story was
going to end with you getting
pissed off at a donkey
[Applause]
I'm sorry it's not your fault smokey
just emblematical about much larger
problem you he hawing piece of
listen we have to fix this system but
before we can even do that we have to
extend it in Iraq the visa program
expired
at the end of last month which I guess
is fine it's not like we're gonna need
translators again there anytime soon and
in Afghanistan they're scheduled to stop
issuing visas altogether on December the
31st meaning that any translator like
Mohammed will be forced to find a friend
and invest in a very good two-piece
pantomime donkey costume to have any
hope of getting into this
country I'm honored to say that we are
actually joined by Mohammed's this
evening ladies gentlemen please welcome
to habits
first thank you so much for being here
and for everything you've done having
fanuc sorry for nothing it's for know
what would you prefer Mohammed or for
knew which is which is better
well now it's it's for knew what for
knew I have a few questions for you know
we've just seen how crazy the visa
process is as a translator I'm
interested what is the Pashto word for
bureaucratic the Posada data
what is the facade
adhara or get word a okay nice that's
good so at least we've all learned a bit
of useful pastel this evening nothing
else look I want a couple of things just
about your situation because working
with the US military you were shot at
twice and survived an ID explosion so I
already guess my first one was why did
you choose to do that job I was working
with British forces and during that time
I met with one of American contractor he
recruited me and it came into me like
come work with other the translator we
need people to help us and I was not by
my own I was i okay how much talk to my
family so I went talk to my family I
talked to my dad he was glad he was a
really excited he's like it's a great
opportunity you're gonna be helping your
country and you're supporting the US
troop that they're here for your country
to rebuild your country so the next day
I signed a contract and stand up for
being a translator to support the US
troop or the coalition forces and help
my country and let's talk a little about
your family now your mom and your
siblings I have left Afghanistan is that
correct yes what why did they leave
because whence they the Taliban they
kidnapped my little brother one time
they killed my dad in the second time
when they kidnapped my little brother so
it's too much we didn't want to take the
third time risk I have to pay them they
left me a note ransom letter it says I
have to pay $35,000 I paid him their
money and they released my dad and my
brother I wish I could that could have
happened to my dad to I could have by
him too but that didn't happen so now
they're hiding
and there they're hiding and they're in
the they haven't involved in this Hail
Mary humanitarian visa application now
on that where this bureaucracy gets even
crazier is if you had been an Iraqi
interpreter your family would have been
eligible to come here under category
five of the direct access program but
Afghanistan does not have a similar
program for no reason whatsoever
my family got because they got hurt
because of me
I lost my dad because of me because of
my job so the process that they have for
us is just a single man that I work for
them here this is the reason s you come
to the United States and I guess I have
one final question is there a word in
Pashto to convey deep gratitude for
someone service but also profound shame
and how they've been treated now really
there isn't really an English either I
can't thank you enough for being here
Mohammed and everything Mohammad ladies
and gentlemen
you